I can't there wasn't one thing sort of
dribs and drabs and years of not working
and then went to drama school and world
when David Mitchell who had met when we
were all students recommended me for a
job so I got my first tele job with them
but then I have another year of no work
so it's sort of all slow I'm not sure I
ever had a it was never a canoeing
moment it was just I really hope I'm
working next month and then bit by bit I
got a bit more working there wasn't I
haven't had a moment ride to work and
I'm gone oh that's it I'm I think I'm
still definitely never selling anymore
films that inspire I'm sure they were
hundreds of them before this point but
nearby mouth and breaking the waves with
two films just breaking the ways I'm not
sure I'll ever be able to watch again
and they were mouths just seen Kathy
Burke do that I don't know those those
moments where I want I want to I want to
do that on it or make people cry or just
be that honest like they were big
moments I think watching those girls
it's such a weird it's not like maths
where there's a right answer it's
everyone you asked to give you a
different answer
I don't know you've got to know you want
to do it and if you've got to really
honest about whether you think you can
and I know my mum asked if I give it
should I suppose you'll give it one year
no I'm going to give it to him and you
know I'm rubbish everything else it's
all I wanted to do so if if and it's not
even fair say for that committee there's
so many of my friends who are that
committed it just doesn't worked out so
I don't know it's a mystery want to do
it beyond time as much again although
I'm being late for it earlier today
and they don't be badly behaved because
there's so many people who want to do it
you're lucky if you are
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]